et c'est donc l'heure dont on va plus
loin comme chaque soir vers 20h40 heures
de Paris on revient ensemble sur deux
informations marquantes de ces dernières
heures en compagnie ce soir de nos
chroniqueurs Gotti robinski de la
rédaction de France 24 et Marc SEMO
journaliste collaborateur journal Le
Monde bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être donc sur ce plateau on va plus
loin tout d'abord ce soir sur la
situation en Israël on est toujours dans
l'attente des résultats définitifs au
législatives mais tout indique que
l'ancien Premier ministre Benyamin
Netanyahoo est en bonne voie pour
revenir aux affaires le liquide et
crédité d'une majorité à l'acnécette
avec
32 sièges devant le parti yashadid de
hier Lapid crédité de 24 sièges quant à
la liste sionisme religieux du député
d'extrême droite si Tamar bengwir elle
serait crédité de 14 sièges un record
l'alliance probable entre son leader le
député d'extrême droite est à marbène et
Benyamin Netanyahou inquiète fortement
côté palestinien on va écouter justement
quelques réactions
le peuple
dans un futur gouvernement israélien des
expériences précédentes ont prouvé que
ces gouvernements n'ont rien de nouveau
à offrir au peuple palestinien au
contraire tous les gouvernements
précédents pratiquaient la pire des
injustices contre nous à Jérusalem en si
Jordanie et à Gaza
aucun des gouvernements formés par
Benyamin Netanyahou au cours des années
précédentes n'a donné ses droits au
peuple palestinien tous ont même rejeté
tous les accords avec l'Autorité
palestinienne
Marx Simo bon il y a encore une petite
incertitude parce qu'on n'a pas les
résultats définitifs il devrait arriver
à priori demain au courant de
l'après-midi mais la tendance semble
quand même se confirmer depuis c'est
clair depuis ce matin le bloc de droite
et donc crédité de 65 sièges a priori un
pari réussi pour Benyamine plus que
parce qu'au début on pensait qu'il est
peut-être gagné mais très serré 61 62
sièges donc c'est c'est beaucoup plus
net c'est une droiteisation évidente de
la société israélienne qui n'est pas une
surprise mais cela va peut-être beaucoup
plus loin qu'on ne le craignait parce
que bon il y a d'un côté n’était miaou
la submersible 15 ans Premier ministre
bout à bout 40 ans de politique
résistait tout et qu'on propose enquêtes
pour corruption il a fallu cinq
élections mais il a finalement retrouvé
la majorité qu'il voulait donc il y a ce
personnage et puis à côté il y a le fait
que mon état n'ya
comment se comporter mais c'est un
pragmatique mais c'est aussi quelqu'un
qui est prêt à tout pour garder le
pouvoir et cette alliance avec Itamar
bengwir et pour le moins préoccupante
pour ce que représente est un marbenvir
qui est
parmi les sinistres religieux ce qui est
de plus extrémiste c'est un suprémiste
ouvertement raciste c'est une formation
marginale avec laquelle personne ne
voulait même avoir le la moindre chose à
faire et qui maintenant avec le temps
grâce à des téniaou grâce à cette
alliance avec Netanyahou et qui est
devenu la troisième force politique
israélienne dans la coalition entre le
liquide et la formation dont est un
arbre benvir et le leader char quand
vous avez 14
députés s'en va avec neset bah c'est pas
une formation marginale vous aurez des
postes importants et à partir de là il y
a de réelles inquiétudes d'autant que la
principale cible de benville au-delà
évidemment des Palestiniens de sa
rhétorique extrêmement violente sur les
Arabes et cetera c'est de remettre au
pas de cacher l'indépendance de la
justice ça cible principale c'est la
Cour suprême justement c'est à dire
c'est faire en sorte que la Cour suprême
qui était une institution profondément
démocratique en Israël ne puisse plus
casser des lois de la cnesset donc
Gauthier la perspective potentielle
c'est la fin de la séparation des
pouvoirs tout simplement en Israël
celui qui s'exprime le mieux sur la
question c'est la colite de Ben clear
qui est à l'aise motrice qui dit il faut
soumettre le judiciaire à l'exécutif
partir de là quand vous faites ça ça
s'appelle plus une démocratie et c'est
là qui a qui a qui a le feu il y a le
feu bien sûr parce qu'on entend des
slogans comme mort aux Arabes
recherche à faire oublier à faire
effacer ses propres casseroles avec une
objective
mais c'est pas encore fait c'est-à-dire
bon ils vont évidemment commencer avec
une coalition avec benvir mais il serait
déjà montré que on les collision change
que on peut faire une coalition d'union
nationale face aux dangers par rapport à
l'Iran par rapport à la guerre en
Ukraine et tout donc c'est pas parce que
benvir rentrera dans ce gouvernement en
coalition avec Netanyahou que
l'Israël cessera d'être une démocratie
c'était et ça sera un processus le
risque est réel il vaut mieux prévoir
que guérir mais les oppositions y
compris au sein du liquide ce sont très
très fortes sur la remise en cause d'un
certain nombre de piliers de ce qui est
les bases même alors de ce qui est
quasiment anoxymore mais quand même
temps une réalité qui a un État juif et
démocratique parce que c'est ça le
produit sionisme c'est un la juifs et
démocratique donc voilà justement
l'abandon d'une partie de ce toxique il
y a ce risque voilà est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer que dans un an hier Lapid
devient numéro 2 de gouvernement de
coalition du nom national avec des ténia
ou voilà et on a entendu justement une
bulle de notre discussion voilà des
réactions de palestinien qui craignent
le pire les concernant quel impact sur
le processus de paix qui était déjà
relégué disons à la périphérie notamment
dans le cadre de cette de cette campagne
alors quand vous voyez la manière dont
Israël enterrine les colonisations de
fait ou qui sont évidemment soutenus par
le pouvoir israélien mais quand vous
voyez la carte cette espèce de de peau
tacheté vous dites effectivement il n'y
a pas de solution il n'y a pas dans
l'immédiat de solution parce que en plus
de cela ce conflit israélo-palestin et
le sort des Palestiniens est sorti
totalement des radars des radars alors
évidemment d'un pouvoir comme celui de
Netanyahu qui au fond repose sur Ethan
Yahoo dit confiez-moi la sécurité vous
faites du faites du business
développez-vous au fond c'est c'est
l'irruption de l'individualisme en
Israël alors que jusqu'à jusqu'au
conservateur jusqu'au liquide en 77
c'était une société mobilisée justement
sur les questions du manisme des
questions d'humanité des questions de
défense du pays mais toujours avec une
morale la netany ou leur dit écoutez la
morale c'est pas la peine travailler
bosser faites-vous du pognon et moi je
m'occupe de la sécurité alors évidemment
quand il dit ça évidemment qu'il n'y a
pas de solution
en territoire palestinien parce que au
fond ce que dit netanyou dans sa
philosophie c'est que nous israéliens
nous serons toujours encerclés nous
serons toujours sur la brèche alors vous
c'est pas la peine
occupez-vous de votre de votre jardin si
j'ose dire et moi je m'occupe du reste
et puis en fin de compte vous voyez
aussi que et pas uniquement à cause de
l'Ukraine que ce dossier palestinien est
sorti des radars depuis bien longtemps y
compris pour les Américains par exemple
qui sont tournés vers d'autres choses
donc il y a là un abandon de fait
dernier point si vous le permettez si
vous ajoutez le fait que la direction
palestinienne est totalement illégitimes
puisqu'elle n'a pas su se renouveler et
qu'elle n'a pas su se soumettre au
suffrage des Palestiniens vous voyez en
quoi effectivement il y a des errance et
ce processus est plus que moribond mais
disons toutes les stratégie de
Netanyahou et en sel la gagner a été de
rendre périphériques de plus en plus
périphérique le dos la question
palestinienne et la question du
processus de paix aujourd'hui la
stratégie de Netanyahou et de normaliser
avec le plus possible de payer arabe et
ça marche ce sont les accords d'Abraham
ça a commencé avec les Émirats arabes
unis le Bahreïn il y a des relations
officieuses pas officielles parce que
MBS ne peut encore franchir le pas quand
même de la reconnaissance mais
extrêmement intense avec l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est franchement avec les pays
arabes devraient se poursuivre et
surtout
ce sont des rapprochements à la fois
pour des raisons de complémentarité
économiques commerciales etc mais aussi
stratégique aujourd'hui la grande ligne
de fracture qui divise le Moyen-Orient
c'est la question de l'Iran et du
nucléaire iranien puisque maintenant
l'accord plus personne n'y croit et que
donc on est dans cette logique ou l'Iran
dans un temps plus ou moins court
deviendra un pays du seuil et donc les
alliances se recomposent et vous trouvez
dans le même camp bon les Émirats arabes
unis l'Arabie Saoudite Israël des
Américains et justement cette logique là
sur ce cette question de de l'Iran et du
nucléaire par rapport à ce qui vient de
dire oui bien sûr parce que les derniers
développements donnent raison au plus
faucon des Israéliens sur l'idée qu'il
n'y a pas à traiter avec l'Iran que
l'Iran d'ailleurs est perdu dans une
fuite en avant à cause aussi des
problèmes internes je voulais juste
ajouter une chose à ce que disait Marc
par rapport aux accords d'Abraham et
l'association avec certains pays arabes
en creux ou accessoirement si vous
voulez ça révèle le caractère totalement
factice du soutien que certains pays
arabes prétendaient apporter à la cause
palestinienne c'est quelque chose
consacrifie volontiers une fois qu'il y
a d'autres choses en jeu sur peut-être
une évolution prévoir dans les rapports
avec la Russie dans le contexte
notamment de la gare ça va être très
compliqué parce que jusqu'ici Israël
avait tenu à garder des liens avec la
Russie parce que la Russie c'est la clé
du ciel syrien du ciel libanais ou
Israël mènent régulièrement des frappes
on avertissant les Russes qui
laissent faire etc donc c'est
stratégiquement un allié important
ensuite les relations entre Netanyahou
d'ailleurs qui revient aux affaires et
Poutine avait toujours été plutôt plutôt
bonne au nom de la réelle politique
chacun pour suit clairement des intérêts
qui sont bien définis voilà la question
maintenant du fait que la Russie
commence de plus en plus à s'associer
militairement avec l'Iran là ce sont ces
l'Iran qui donne des drones à la Russie
mais la Russie aujourd'hui alors qu'au
début elle continuait malgré la guerre
en Ukraine à faire pression pour arriver
à un accord sur le nucléaire aujourd'hui
la Russie laisse faire totalement l'Iran
peut changer la donne alors on ne sait
pas dans quel sens parce que que à la
fois la nécessité pour Israël de garder
des liens avec la Russie et peut-être
encore plus vital si la question de
denucléaire iranien devient encore de
plus en plus chaude d'un autre côté il
peut aussi y avoir l'effet inverse qui
est celui de dire voilà il y a un esprit
une espèce de de formation de blog
d'alliance et Israël bascule du côté
clairement des Américains de l'Ukraine
etc dans ce bras de fer avec la Russie
alors autre thème non on va plus loin ce
soir notre scrutin législatif d'ailleurs
au Danemark cette fois où le bloc de
gauche de la première ministre sortante
la sociale démocrate méthodes
frédéricsen s'est assuré une majorité au
Parlement a priori 90 sièges sur les 179
contre le Parlement danois une majorité
Gautier une majorité de justesse a
priori des tractations devrait s'entamer
avec le parti centriste
c'est pas la gauche c'est plus la gauche
quand vous voyez le résultat des parties
d'extrême droite alors il y en a plus ou
moins deux un qui a été fondé par la
ministre de l'Immigration et qui a
préféré faire cavalier celle mais c'est
parti ont été véritablement notamment le
Parti du peuple danois siphonnés depuis
facilement on va aller on va dire 15-20
ans siphonner de leur contenu
discriminants anti-étranger xénophobe
par d'abord les conservateurs et
aujourd'hui les sociodes démocrates qui
ont une législation
ultra restrictive vis-à-vis des immigrés
vis-à-vis de la nationalité danoise et
qui cerise sur le gâteau et c'est là
qu'on peut vraiment dire qu'il y a
quelque chose de pourri au royaume du
Danemark cerise sur le gâteau c'est
l'idée que aujourd'hui par exemple pour
les réfugiés syriens le gouvernement
danois considère que la situation est
suffisamment pacifiée en Syrie pour
qu'ils y rent
bon alors vous voyez où ça mène
l'extrême droite y compris quand elle
chute l'extrême droite au Danemark elle
est pas très importante mais quand elle
déteint de la sorte sur des forces on va
dire traditionnelles que ça soit les
conservateurs c'est même le paradoxe les
conservateurs sont en train de devenir
beaucoup plus sensible à la question des
immigrés ne serait-ce que pour s'opposer
aux sociaux-démocrates
au Danemark sur cette politique
migratoire très ferme comment est-ce
qu'on
mais de la part des sociaux-démocrates
bon ça a été les les derniers à basculer
mais ce qui est intéressant et à
certains égards glaçants c'est comment
mettez frédéricsen a combiné les deux
choses qui sont d'un côté la défense de
l'État providence le système danois du
système de santé ben elle a fait
énormément campagne sur la question du
système de santé qui comme en France les
infirmières les médecins tous s'en vont
etc donc il y a une urgence à maintenir
le système de français la qualité des
soins et de l'autre la question d'une
politique extrêmement restrictive
extrêmement soudure sur l'immigration
sur l'accès même à la citoyenneté
danoise en disant voilà on ne peut pas
tout faire on ne peut pas avoir un état
social ouvert à tous donc il faut pour
le moment verrouiller de telle manière
qu'on puisse intégrer ce qui sont déjà
là en même temps remettre sur pied les
les approvidence et ensuite on verra et
donc comme ça
c'est triste mais de fait les
sociaux-démocrates ont gardé leur
électorat populaire ouvriers mettaient
Frédéric scène fait deux points de plus
de points et demi de plus coup
précédentes élections donc cette espèce
de manière de combiner la défense de
l'État-providence et une politique très
ferme sur l'immigration à électoralement
était très payant alors oui j'ajoute que
ça porte sur l'État-providence mais
aussi d'une manière beaucoup plus
pernicieuse sur un certain nombre de
valeurs et de ce point de vue ça
ressemble un peu à ce que faisait
vilders au Pays-Bas qui disait l'islam
les musulmans sont là pour nous
cisailler nos valeurs progressistes et
c'est au nom du progressisme et au
Danemark c'est également ça c'est-à-dire
au nom par exemple des droits de la
femme au nom de des homosexuels etc ce
que dit le gouvernement danois c'est les
musulmans sont là pour finalement nous
priver de nos valeurs qui sont si
progressistes vous voyez donc c'est pas
une extrême droite au sens
apparition comme on peut la voir par
exemple en France ou celle qui s'inspire
de de principe type pétains ou
Révolution nationale là c'est beaucoup
plus pernicieux parce qu'on dit vous
êtes pour cette gauche danoise qui est
effectivement a fait beaucoup de choses
et bien il faut la protéger au point
même que l'on chasse ou qu'on est en
train de chasser des enfants ou des
adolescents qui sont né au Danemark et
qui sont nationalité danoise et on leur
dit vous ne remplissez pas tous les
critères c'est à dire vous êtes danois
mais vous n'êtes pas complètement vous
voyez jusqu'où ça peut aller ce genre de
choses merci beaucoup Gauthier merci
aussi à vous Marc pour vos éclairages
donc sur les législatives en Israël et
au Danemark rester avec nous sur France
24 prochain point complet sur
l'actualité d'ici quelques minutes
[Musique]